match-up draft time for week 12. chris
you got the trivia question i do michael
thomas is leading the nfc and the nfl in
receiving yards who
michael florio is leading the afc in
receiving yards don't look say right
here keep your eyes up i don't dueling
that's going on who this is this is a
man who's who jumps out to me i know
it's always here
that's a weird yeah there really isn't a
guy that you say absolutely positively
this is the guy right uh
man i'm just gonna have to it can't be
deandre hopkins he hasn't had a big year
i have no idea i know it's a tough one i
it's it's obvi it's like you're gonna be
like oh man but it's not like you
wouldn't think it so you're giving
jarvis landry nope good guess uh but it
is travis kelsey
travis that's not obvious well i know
it's it's it's it's a they don't expect
it to be a tight end you're right it's
crazy right it is it's a weird year at
the receiver position there's other than
michael thomas nobody putting up like
huge stats or anything like that
um that's a tough question that's kind
of a trick question we kind of we got
peter king yesterday with a trick
question so we're even now i guess yep
okay so good job guys way to make florio
eat it all right and the match-up uh
that i think jumps out to me more than
any this weekend
will be
kellen moore versus bill belichick that
is to me an intriguing one kellen moore
first year play caller for the dallas
cowboys doing a great job you know has a
lot of assets at his disposal as far as
run game offensive line weapons of
receiver a quarterback who's top notch
and now he's playing the defense that's
clearly the best defense he's had to
play this year who not only is really
talented in the secondary but then you
got a coach who
does game plan specific things on a
weekly basis to where you just you can't
prepare for it you don't know where bill
might go and do and something is one of
his outside the box type of thoughts to
take away a part of your game plan that
you were not expecting to be
uh taken away and to me that will be one
of the interesting things i watch i do
think this offense poses some problems
like i said earlier for this new england
defense and can be a handful for them
because of their balance and their
weapons and things like that and i'm
just interested to see where it goes you
know does he put gilmore on you know
amari cooper or does he go gilmore on
the second best receiver and double
amari cooper there's just so many ways
what does he do to stop the run in
certain down and distances so that's one
that really jumps out to me
and you know it's funny when you put it
that way because you suggested earlier
in the show that the cowboys could
surprise the patriots when you boil it
down to kellen moore versus bill
belichick yeah
patriots buy a billion in this
so
uh i i think you you've helped me you've
helped me resolve what my picks gonna be
okay for uh for that game when we do the
mega pix podcast later on uh in the
morning all right i i'm gonna go with
something that you had suggested earlier
that i hadn't thought about and i'm glad
you didn't make it your first round pick
the the kyle shanahan
damn
sorry you should have picked it first
gosh but
you've got you've got kyle shanahan who
was the offensive coordinator for mike
pettin in 2014. and that was the year
with johnny manziel and and shanahan
asked out after the year and they let
him leave so there's got to you know we
we got into the whole
hard feelings that kyle shanahan has for
washington earlier this year i don't
know if he has hard feelings for mike
pettin specifically but it sounds like
it was kind of a dysfunctional year mike
pettin knows kyle shanahan's offense
because he ran kyle shanahan's offense
the first year he was a head coach of
the cleveland browns i i just kind of
like how how this one shakes out pat
knows shanahan shanahan knows pettin
shanahan's got some guys who are banged
up patton's had two weeks to get ready
for this one i you know i i we like the
49ers in this one generally but uh if
there's a team that's going to catch
them
with two weeks to get ready for the game
i i you know with that mike patton
defense and they have not done much in
recent weeks maybe this is an
opportunity for patton to remind
everyone that their defense isn't quite
as bad as we would say yeah right i i
mean i'm with you yeah totally i mean
that's to me it's a really cool matchup
plus matt lafleur who came from kyle
shanahan you know as far as under his
coaching tree and also matt leflore's
little brother it's the passing game
coordinator for the san francisco 49ers
so there is a lot of familiarity between
both coaching staffs here as far as what
the one and the other does and uh i do
think that's going to be one of the cool
things to watch all right i'm going to
one of the marquee games at one o'clock
and i'm going to the seahawks eagles
game specifically the seahawks defensive
line versus the eagles offensive line
that to me will go a long way
to
who wins this football game the seahawks
pass defense as we know has not been
great all year now the eagles pass
offense nothing special either
but i do think they're creative enough
and good enough to where if this
seahawks d-line can apply some pressure
and dominate the line of scrimmage a
little bit that the eagles will have
some plays that are there to be had
against that seattle secondary and i you
know again i'm really excited to see off
of bye week
if seattle's d-line can play like they
did against the san francisco 49ers then
seattle is like a legit
we can win the super bowl type team i
think i had him in the category as legit
nfc pain in the butt going into that
game and if joe deviant clowney and
jaron reed and and ezekiel anza and you
know puna ford and all of them can can
play up to the way we saw that night
they are in a different stratosphere to
me and that would go a long way to help
their past secondary out and really shut
down the eagles in general to where i
think that's a huge matchup in the game
and they are hot on the hill still the
49ers if they would win on sunday and
the 49ers lose the seahawks jump into
first place in the nfc west clowny by
the way didn't practice due to injury on
wednesday so that's one to monitor over
the course what was it is it
do you know did they say i don't know i
would have mentioned it i would have
mentioned it if i if i had it right in
front of me i don't have it right in
front of me i tried to gloss over it so
thank you for exposing that i don't
immediately know what it is totally
we'll find out yeah we'll let you know
stats will let us know all right i'm
gonna go to a game that i probably could
have held this one to round three
um
i will hold it to round three let me do
this one
mitchell trubisky versus matt maggie
that's the match-up because we are now
at the point where when the bears play
the giants this weekend i know it's not
a game that that is going to receive a
ton of attention but it's reached the
point where
it makes sense to have a camera on those
guys all the time every interaction they
have every reaction that matt neggie has
to something that happens on the field
because we have that that layer of drama
and dysfunction that emerged late in the
game on sunday the hip injury that was
or wasn't the benching that did or
didn't happen the images of the two of
them huddled together and and and i
think that how those guys interact how
they're able to get together or not get
together every interaction between them
is going to be scrutinized it's going to
be criticized potentially and it's going
to go a long way toward determining
whether or not the bears can salvage a
season that every week i look at their
record and i say how are they four and
six it feels like there's so much worse
than that i think the reason it feels
that way is because bears fans are so
deflated over the fact that this is a
team that was 12 and four a year ago and
they had high hopes for another playoff
trip this year but i think trubisky
versus nagi at every level how they
handle the relationship how we see it
unfold
every every image every shot every time
he's on the sideline it's going to be a
major focus in that giants bears game on
sunday yeah i'm with you and i'll say uh
this
you know
i was i'm wrong okay i'm apologizing to
matt nagy uh or the bears and the bears
fans for those who were i challenged
whether trubisky was you know hurt
because i saw enough on film yesterday
and saw a tweet from olin croots the
great offensive lineman from the chicago
bears who first saw a tweet there and
then i was getting ready to watch the
game on film and saw it that yeah there
was a problem in the tribeski's hit i
don't think it was like earth-shattering
horrible hurt like that but there
definitely was so i stand corrected you
know me i like to self-scout thyself and
within doing that i was wrong uh and i
just want everybody out there to know to
know that all right
so if you take that much time to explain
every time you're wrong our show is
gonna consist of you constantly talking
about all the things you were wrong you
know what screw you floria i think
that's the first time i've been wrong in
weeks
all right
i'm gonna go to the monday night match
up this is one that jumps out to me of
course i'm really excited to watch this
game but i think one matchup if the rams
wanted to win this football game
it comes down to this a little bit
jaylen ramsey on hollywood brown
i'd really look at that as being a
marquee matchup of the weekend because
if the rams want to pull off the upset
and they want to be able to stop you
know lamar jackson and all the running
game and the ravens and overpowering
them and all that stuff they're going to
need jalen ramsey to be on an island
against hollywood brown and basically
just take him out of the game so they
can use other assets in coverage and in
the run game to help out with all the
creative things that the baltimore
ravens do in the run game i think that
will go a long way if the rams can kind
of if he can shut down hollywood brown
and give wade phillips you know the
confidence there he'll be able to do
some creative things that i think can
give that ravens offense some issues we
know that ram's defense has been
phenomenal and i do think the rams can i
mean you know rams defense can muck it
up m with the m
muck it up the game a little bit with
all their chaos and creativity they have
up front with aaron donald and dante
flower and brockers and all those guys
so that one one that uh stands out to me
you just like to move your hand as close
to the flame as you can no that's what i
do
davey and clowny by the way knee and hip
injuries thank you stats for that
information all right mine is and this
would have been bigger if they had
gotten together earlier in the year this
is the first time the falcons and the
bucks get together this year which means
it's the first time former buccaneers
coach dirk cutter gets a shot by the
buccaneers dirk cutter versus the
buccaneers all the knowledge he has of
the personnel specifically jameis
winston and you know it's kind of a
strange week because cutter's got to get
his offense ready but i have a feeling
he's going to be working with dan quinn
and the defensive coaching staff to
download any and all information about
how to confuse and confound jameis
winston if anyone knows it's dirk cutter
who worked with winston longer than
anyone uh at the at the nfl level and uh
dirk's got he's got a little uh a little
fire there
a little cantankerous i've been on the
wrong end of it once or twice actually
all it took was once for me to
understand to steer clear from this guy
and there's some of the things he said
this week you know he knows there's
there's a little more to it and
it's an elimination game i don't think
either teams got a shot at making to the
playoffs but they're both three and
seven the loser is definitely done the
winner still has a shot and uh we'll
make our picks in that game coming up
later today in the
mega joint
so
those are our picks if you're watching
on tv
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports